this is my dream yo look all my shit
look at this shit I got I got fucking
amiibos every fucking color look at this
shit come over here
I got Donkey Kong look at all this shit
this ain't no predator
it's a fucking art piece yo I got Dragon
Ball Z on repeat Greg Ball Z on repeat
springbreakers
great James Franco performance check it
out don't worry I'm not gonna do the
whole video like that if you guys were
wondering what I was doing at the time I
wonder what I'm doing - this is my new
filming location we bought a new house
and I've been setting this up over the
past month to two months really we
painted it this was a disgusting nasty
color before with this horrific like
1982 wallpaper it's all gone now and we
got LED lights to really make everything
shine
we have LEDs on the blu-rays we have
LEDs behind the shelves so up here I
have amiibo shows I decided to put all
the amigos across the entire room you
can actually follow around the whole
room and see that I've placed them
across the entire room because you know
I just really like Nintendo I guess what
can I say over here I'm going to have my
anime collection and this was actually
in the basement at our old place but now
I have room in my office for it because
contrary to what you might think just by
watching my videos now that office that
I film in it's like a glorified closet
really I have to work to make sure that
my voice doesn't sound like a horrible
echo and like it's in some little atrium
because I am I have a much bigger space
now which I'm really excited about these
two display cases my mother-in-law and
my wife actually found at a yard sale
and that was really awesome they bought
it for me as a gift and over here are
going to be my Dragon Ball Z's obviously
I'm a huge fan a lot of these are
Banpresto you can get a lot of them at
the big bad toy store over here I'm
going to have some hot toys this is
going to be my official hot toy shelf
those take a while to collect because
they're really expensive right now I
have black widow Indiana Jones
and thank you to a very awesome viewer
who I will not say his name just in case
he wants to remain anonymous for that
ant-man that was very awesome
to get in the mail thank you very much
so my god most excited about is this TV
with my videos now I film with the DSLR
and I still do but there's always a bit
of guesswork when I sit down in front of
it because I don't have a camera
operator I don't have someone who's
focusing for me I'm doing that all on my
own
now I don't have to worry about that
because I'm going to use this as an
external monitor I'm going to connect
the camera through HDMI to this TV and
I'll be able to actually sit down and
see in 40 inch 1080p
how good the shot is or if it looks
really shitty and that's something I'm
super excited about because right now
the way I film I just have this little
LCD screen that sort of flips out and it
can be a little bit of a guesswork
they've been many times where I've
actually filmed a video entirely and
then gone to the editing room and
realized that it's just a hair out of
focus and even though some people might
not notice that it's going to bug a shit
out of me so now this external monitor I
don't have to do that what I love about
these LEDs is you can change the color
this is my favorite color that I'll
probably use all the time but let's just
say I really hate a movie I can go bold
red for age the red doesn't show up that
well though so there's all different
types of things I can do I sometimes
just sit here and stare at it to be
honest because it's just so beautiful
but that is my new filming location this
is my new office I'm gonna start filming
in here probably within the next one to
two weeks I didn't want it to just be
like boom here's my new place and have
everyone be like wait where are you so I
thought it'd be nice if I could show you
a tour and let you guys know what it
looks like first I don't know exactly
what video will be the first video here
but within one that you weeks I'm gonna
be filming here thank you so much as
always for watching guys and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes there my shit my shit I
got my blue kublai